hello there reject nation of Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey with Halloween
approaching us it's time to get into
spooky spirits of things we're gonna
watch a short film called spook train a
room one curtains oh snap
Lee Hardcastle holy crud who's that um
I've seen a couple of his works before
he makes these really off-the-wall
claymation shorts he did I think an
intro for the Simpsons that went viral
at one point that's like out there and
strange he sent some Rick and Morty
stuff Wow you know thing we're in for a
wild ride this is a topper war tear
video requests from a man named Eric
horseman who one day we will visit in
Atlanta you have my word about that Eric
because you got a real rejects tattoo
pure guilt one of the best motivators in
the world let's watch this
[Music]
gay pride baby gay pride whoo
Oh sounds like
[Music]
[Music]
see why is mental problems
oh no not the old lady
[Music]
cinematography is great
Oh No
Oh
Oh No
what no no no
your teeth yeah
get back to the crossword puzzles what
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
look
boys
she died peacefully in his sleep
huh I don't exactly know but I guess the
doctor like the medicine was poison or
something
Wow it was all like a ruse so that he
can the doctor could be the guy I don't
know I'm just interpreting that little
ending note there well what did you
think
how'd you do it really committed aren't
you excited to see The Simpsons go
through something like oh gosh I was you
know the days of YouTube doing videos
like this have a haven't seen videos
like this in a long time you know yeah
covering these kind of short films or
weird videos back in the day that led to
a lot of very popular reactions on this
channel
it's been so long cuz of those damdi
monetization CL dollar bills signs that
no one really covers them anymore but
then to watch this again one part of it
was like it's cool to be watching a
violent horror weird trippy video on the
internet once again and then the other
part was oh my god I did not expect this
to go that far
that was that was nuts I love it for its
level of commitment to it it's so bleak
psychologically messed up and just how
violent it gets like you can get away
with the amount of violence just because
it's claymation
at the same time allele of this was real
life I would I would have no business
with this I would not enjoy if these
were like actual humans and you're
watching this real just disturbing gonna
watch an old lady get be to be like I
hate this this is just mean-spirited
nasty but in claymation form a really
admirable about it who you logged in
together yeah
and the voice acting is great yeah it's
it has that quality where it's like a
little force of nature trapped in a
short film package where like it's so
strange I don't understand all of it at
this exact moment since we've finished
the video
it just seems so confident in what
exactly it's doing and like the
cinematography is so composed it is
disconcerting in a way that yeah is like
uncomfortable because of how
hyper-violent it is but also yeah again
kind of pleasant cuz it's nice to see
something that's as gonzo and lo-fi and
also you know has a certain amount of
ingenuity given the medium it's you know
portrayed I mean yeah from a story
purpose because it starts off with the
the brother right the brother was as
dead I couldn't tell I think it was the
brother he's earned a Gay Pride jacket
right yeah and then he crap I don't have
made it seem like it was an accident of
what occurred maybe he took these pills
first maybe they did hit a animal in the
road no but maybe this was all a
hallucination just before she died in
the chair after having taken the pills
and thus maybe we saw his hallucination
because there's that whole thing about
remember what the doctor said
won't feel a thing he'll be
instantaneous or whatever that was I
don't know again it's it's open to
interpretation I would imagine I mean
there's the I mean there's seems some
pretty clear character stuff though that
did occur the son who were focusing on
who the son to this mother is gay and
she says that whole thing about it was
find a nice girl find a nice girl but
she also says the thing about you know
it's better way to die than AIDS which
is often referenced with the the gay
community as an insult so she seems like
she's probably like homophobic
disapproving and when you do cut to the
doctor when the guys remembering he does
like open his legs in a seductive format
and then with the end yap around would
finally be together yeah so it seemed
like he was one of those kind of likes
weird relationships norman bates ish i
don't know if it goes that far because
he didn't try to kill his own mom but at
the same time it's like this guy was
clearly keeping a secret from his mother
is this weird liberating thing with that
character if he's like depressed when
his mom dies and it has its instant
direct reaction to go make out with a
doctor and the doctor is like really the
villain of all this you know yeah so
yeah i mean the way the guy died did the
brother or dad whatever the guy in the
motorcycle and that could have been part
of the back character's hallucination or
something yeah yeah
yes maybe it was a similar kind of
you'll go peacefully but not suffer
guys taking revenge at the disapproving
mom ya know is that it could be that
what I should be rooting for could could
be maybe this old lady is a homophobe
and really does a lot for that community
and these monsters were correct in doing
it in in brutal I don't know I mean you
know in a strange way if you choose to
interpret it that way it does that thing
where it forces you to go how far is too
far for a person that has a deplorable
something-or-other point of view or yeah
a view or whatever you know at what
point do we start resynthesizing with
somebody and she was still torn away
from the one she loves though and
literally torn away and she's literal as
possible she's something very sweet even
if she was a bit homophobic so very
disturbing nevertheless but I do also
like this concept of you know what if
someone doesn't die peacefully in their
sleep they just have it's like yeah for
some it is like horrific nightmarish
debt that you're having hallucinatory
just torture yeah yeah but then you know
a doctor checks onions like they died in
their sleep yeah you're being sucked
into the black hole of the void of the
universe you know this is one of those
videos that you know I feel like in the
old days people would be like constantly
interpreting making ss videos on this so
it was cool to see to me what I consider
vintage YouTube yeah it's a geek show
that you can chew on and think about
alright guys well what did you think a
spook train comment below what are your
theories and what the video means or
what it's all about you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification mother get notified
whenever we got a youtube video up you
can check us out on patreon where we do
weekly q and A's TV show reactions
stream along sync up with us or you
there are some shows that have the
option of reaction highlights to be
included go ahead and do that as well
and he does music video covers weekly
Eric thanks for requesting this my dude
my handsome handsome man I guess I had
the theory that this dealt with you know
da guys getting back at the
homophobic mom cuz eric is gay and he
and he's living his mom this is his
fantasy that he has about her he just
wants the murder this was actually a
custom video Lee Hardcastle made for
Internet Eric and said I have an idea
I'm gonna make this just for you yeah I
could see how that's possibly it Eric I
hope you're doing okay I hope the
drinking and the pills with by yourself
or not being too difficult on your liver
on your body I hope but at the end of it
all you're still living a peaceful life
peaceful and the way how this grandma
died yeah totally peaceful no harm no
foul this is a bleak shadow I hope you
enjoy